[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con el día de
hoy con el escritor periodista y editor
argentino oche califa hablaremos sobre
la lucha de las librerías por la
supervivencia en época de pandemia sin
público sin ferias y con perdidas
bienvenidos a france 24 y quiero empezar
preguntándole por esta supervivencia de
las librerías que en espacios físicos
siempre ha sido un desafío los esfuerzos
de los libreros son constantes para
primero animar a la gente a leer más
y segundo animarlos a que sigan
eligiendo el papel por encima de lo
digital usted diría que en pandemia la
tienen más difícil
buenos días y por supuesto la respuesta
es positiva es bastante más difícil
nosotros entramos a argentina entró en
el 20 de marzo en cuarentena y eso
obligó a las librerías a cerrar
absolutamente por supuesto además la
producción editorial ya venía frenándose
frente a esta posibilidad y este eso
tuvo un mes así gestiones de las cámaras
y de nosotros la fundación del libro
logramos que en principio se permitiera
abrir para el envío a domicilio servicio
que la mayoría de las editoriales desde
las librerías tienen no hay que entender
que en argentina el circuito comercial
es el principal para el negocio del
libro tenemos más de 1200 librerías
pero a lo largo de toda nuestra
geografía así que es absolutamente vital
y además el 70% de esas 1200 o más son
del dueño único es decir no pertenecen a
cadenas finalmente logramos que pudieran
empezar con el envío nosotros en
fundación el libro que somos los
organizadores de la feria internacional
del libro de buenos aires armamos
rápidamente un mapa de librerías
argentinas mostrando todo cómo se
prestaban los servicios de recepción de
pedidos y envíos no y luego en distintos
distritos se fue habilitando la
situación pública pero todavía tenemos
en las grandes ciudades sobre todo una
circulación restringida de personas con
lo cual digamos que bien no entra
demasiada gente a la librería el
aislamiento social trae también una
oportunidad para que la gente se vuelque
o se vuelque hacia la lectura dejando
atrás otros afanes que traía la
normalidad que conocíamos antes de la
pandemia
la lectura podría ser una de ellas el
kobe 19 nos puso a leer
y bueno es difícil medirlo no esas cosas
luego se dicen sobre la base de
impresiones o de anécdotas pero
seguramente en la gente tiene más tiempo
en sus casas incluso porque el que
trabaja en su casa no tiene el tiempo de
traslado a trabajo es decir hay más
disposición de tiempo en hogar se sale
menos y seguramente hay más posibilidad
la gente que tiene una biblioteca
seguramente tiene libros que no leyó no
y además se pueden adquirir para
recibirlos esa posibilidad seguramente
y este tiene que estar siguiendo
aprovechar
h hay tantos temas tantos autores como
arena y en el mar usted como librero que
orientación les daría a nuestros
televidentes para decidir su siguiente
lectura teniendo en cuenta la ansiedad
general que se vive por estos días
bueno en realidad la producción por lo
menos en argentina ha comenzado
lentamente a retomarse hay alguna
algunas novedades y lanzamientos que
finalmente se están produciendo y este y
en esa medida el autor favorito o la
saga de interés favorita empieza a
encontrar novedades para aquel que
estaba demandando las que yo creo que es
la oportunidad para repasar lecturas los
que somos lectores no y también para
buscar por los distintos intereses
lectores a veces cuando hablamos de
libros la gente inmediatamente piensa en
literatura pero hay mucha gente que lee
divulgación científica hay gente que le
política y la gente que la ciencia
temática de ciencias sociales para todo
eso hay lecturas y no nos olvidemos que
el libro la herramienta principal de la
cultura humana porque funciona no solo
expresando la cultura sino esté
trabajando como reservorio como lugar de
memoria todo lo humano tiene un libro
incluso hay libros de cocina libros de
deportes de lo que fuere
es una buena oportunidad gracias 8 se
nos acaba el tiempo pero a ustedes
gracias por sus impresiones y sus
recomendaciones y nuestros televidentes
sigan en france 24
[Música]